let's talk about revolution on nbc first
of all congratulations the show is doing
fantastic
yeah people love the show and it's a
cool idea
you always have cool ideas set 15 years
after the world has lost its power yeah
this is eric kripke's uh he created the
show and it's it's his cool idea um but
the notion is kind of a a kind of a
cautionary tale kind of a wish
fulfillment you know we're in this crazy
world of just electromagnetic waves and
phones and information and it's just
it's loud it's noisy it's crazy part of
it is like it's kind of beautiful when
it all goes away and part of it is
kind of terrifying because everything
shifts you know the people who are in
control people who are the most
comfortable are suddenly running for
their lives and terrified and i think
i i don't think i could survive more
than you know 15 minutes with you know
without really well i mean it's funny
because we all think about we all do
think about how would i do in that kind
of world i always think like well i've
kind of gotten by all right in a world
where there's like tv cameras i can act
like an ass but if they took all of that
away
and i had to make something with my
hands or go and find my food it was a
terrifying idea right
i mean i'd be amazing i think
i think i'd totally be great i i don't i
it's just it is a kind of terrifying
sort of the the vicarious quality i
think is really kind of interesting like
there before the grace of god go why
what would i do if that were me i think
it's the premise i thought was pretty
pretty cool do you really think you
wouldn't last that long seriously like i
gotta tell you you know like uh our
daughter gracie does a little you know
archery and so i'd stick with her but i
gotta tell you i don't know who i don't
know how i would you know it's like i
i'm hungry
it's like gracie help me out
father i have broccoli
uh
i i feel like probably more likely
father i brought us a target yeah
but it'd be like you know if you have to
get food it's like what would i do i'd
be like i'm gonna go find the knife yeah
certainly
we all become woody allen in that
situation not just you but even irish
catholic guys are like getting nauseous
i don't know like you know
andy you'd be looking at another rat and
i think you'd be fine i really do um
yeah
i could i could well i could at least
build a lien to and uh defend it uh you
know with my fat little fists
i i have some friends who are like
survivalists like campers yeah i would
just try to find them and stick with
them yeah stick with those guys we're so
out of time but i i must now get to the
uh clip from from revolution which is a
terrific show and as you said this is a
a society which is 15 years now without
yeah it's a post-power show not
post-apocalyptic it's not you know we've
all seen the mad max thing where people
are running around with mohawks and
right yeah riding motorcycles this is a
post 15 years post power okay anything
else we need to know for this clip uh
it's got uh our lovely uh giancarlo
esposito in it let's check it out let's
do it shall we
your best friend murdered my father
which uh
let's be honest was probably no big loss
right
captain neville
what
if you want me dead just kill me
otherwise
i'd like some water please
you heard the boy
give him some water
so great
[Applause]